the north-east of Africa's touches the
first mile the Nuba Mountains and the
pyramids of meroe together this diverse
geography once formed Africa's largest
country Sudan this is the story of how
Sudan became two nations and an ongoing
conflict that has changed the lives of
millions of people the British colonized
the region in 1898 and governed the
North and the South differently the
North primarily love a Muslim received
most of the investment from the British
and the south when people follow
Christianity and other religions the
pretty suppressed economic development
and empowered to let tribal leaders to
divide and roll both the North and the
South fought to expel their colonial
rulers and one dose of determination in
1956 the two regions were brought
together to form Sudan with the
political economic and cultural
differences for deep
[Music]
after winning independence from Britain
Southern Sudan hoped for greater 70
instead it will under the governance of
the north finance broke out
immediately the next few decades are a
series of civil wars and failed peace
agreements over two million people died
in 2005 the north are yourselves signed
a new peace deal but it left some
borders in dispute
including the Nova mountain as millions
of people in South Sudan celebrate
independence troops were sent to nuba
mountains armed rebels so many here had
fought with the south the new orders
left the region the nose
four thousand songs drop on civilians
villages
hospitals and schools where the Sudanese
government many are forced to hide in
case to stay safe the government has
also blocked in maintaining aid
despite food shortages at least ninety
seven thousand civilians has fled across
the borders to South Sudan let's meet
the people who are experiencing this
crisis in the Nuba Mountains we'll hear
from a rebel fighter a journalist at
this place mother trying to keep our
children safe and a young girl trying to
continue her education